but anyway what you need to know today
begins in pittsburgh as chris sims
mentioned
ben roethlisberger with the
elbow injury he didn't bang it on
anything so when did he actually injure
it when did it go what happened he
exited the game and here's the thing
when you have a history of
leaving a game and then coming back and
he gets a hard time for embellishing boy
well the wolf ate ben roethlisberger
yesterday because he was gone he came
back and was on the sidelines everybody
thought he was going to come back on the
field he didn't mason rudolph takes over
ben roethlisberger will have an mri
today to find out the extent of the
damage but the pittsburgh steelers
without ben roethlisberger i mean
i don't know how good they are with him
right but they sure as hell aren't very
good without him they still made it
competitive maybe mason rudolph feeling
a little better about himself he's just
kind of got that wide-eyed doughy look
about him worse right like i i i was a
senior in high school i went to bed i
woke up and now i'm the starting
quarterback of the pittsburgh steelers
what the hell do i do he's got to lose
that look yeah he does i mean if he
wants to give the team confidence uh you
know in himself and the fact that he can
orchestrate drives and and and of course
lead the offense he's going to have to
take it to that level but huge blow
concerning with the injury mike really
is because
it's more concerning to me that we can't
find
a hit that actually did it that to me
scares me that oh this might be like the
jake deloam there's something
ligament-wise that might have been
slightly torn and i know this is all
speculation at this point and i don't
know but when i see a quarterback throw
the ball like that without contact and
then grabbing the elbow
it looked more than like something like
tendinitis where we saw from brett favre
back in like the 2000s
and that's scary and just some of the
conversations you saw on the sidelines
with the trainer and the seriousness of
the talks it just it's scary all
together let alone yes the team is
playing like crap and they don't look
good well that'll be one of the nuggets
that will hit at some point today when
roethlisberger has the mri and the
results are made available to the team
made available to the player someone
will say something to someone in the
media even though the steelers ideally
would like to keep it close to the vest
because what you want to do is you want
to line up whoever it is you're going to
acquire i don't know whether you can
with a jaguar say hey we'll give you
josh dobbs back for a third round pick
we got him for a fifth round you want
him back you want somebody else but
that's the thing teams like to keep it
very quiet so they can get the best
possible deal if they trade for a backup
or if they sign a backup because if you
know ben roethlisberger's out for x
you know what and then i don't want to
put a number on it and then oh yeah
florio said he's gonna be out for the
year but i'm saying if you know and it's
out there it's more leverage if they
know it's worse than what maybe they
think it is right and the other thing
that stinks for them you know it's a
tough spot of the the season even though
it's early right i mean you've seen guys
like proven backups like a brian hoyer
and josh mccown who are already gone i
mean we saw josh mccown help the eagles
last night and put them in position to
to get points before the first half was
over so yeah i don't know you know
listen they're in deep trouble they're
in deep trouble with or without ben
roethlisberger right now often defense
given up too many big plays offense
can't seem to get it going as far as
explosive plays in the pass game and
pittsburgh there's no run game and now
james connor's beat up too and you just
wonder how they can weather this storm
and we thought that based upon the
departures of le'veon bell and antonio
brown all the negativity being directed
at the steelers they would find a way to
come together and prove all the doubters
wrong and stick it to a b and stick it
to le'veon bell but you only got to have
players yes you do and look here's the
thing just because tom brady is still
going strong at age 42 and looking as
good as ever does not mean that all of
these guys who are getting closer and
closer to 40 are going to be able to
continue to go indefinitely some of
these guys are going to get injured some
of these guys are going to start to see
their skills diminish right and with
brothels burger here's an injury that
may be not from
any specific thing happening but just
overuse overuse who knows over age right
maybe not enough use maybe not arm and
shape in the off season i don't know
there's a lot of different things you
could say to that
think about it i mean look at i mean ben
rothersburg does not look like the kind
of guy who was obsessed with keeping
himself in the best possible shape well
he told me that during the little
interview you saw me with the
quarterback mechanics and things like
that that he doesn't throw the ball much
in the off season and you know sometimes
that okay you don't throw the ball a lot
in the off season all of a sudden you're
throwing 200 balls a day in training
camp and you know things like this can
happen i'm hoping for the best because
that could really deter his career at
the end to have that type of injury and
he signed that contract three years with
the steelers he's under contract with a
huge signing bonus that he got so uh
we'll see how that plays out for him
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports